all right we've looked at all of the
individual pieces of the critical
rendering path now let's take a look at
an end-to-end view and see how the
timeline comes together possible it's
exactly what I need to keep things
manageable we'll use our hello world
page that has a few inline CSS Styles
some text and an image let's refresh to
capture the full trace okay let's see
what's going on here as you would expect
first we see the request go out for the
HTML document next we get an event
showing that the server returned some
response headers followed by some data
that's our HTML next up the browser
begins parsing the HTML this is where
the browser is converting the received
bytes to the Dom tree and in fact if we
expand this note you can see that our
document parser finds the embedded image
reference and initiates the request once
that is done it continues to parse the
HTML and once it gets to the end it
constructs the CSS object model in this
example our CSS was inline directly into
the page so there are no CSS requests
next the browser builds the render tree
and computes all the styles for the
content that should be visible on the
screen that's what this recalculate
style event indicates once that's done
we continue to layout which as you now
know is where we compute the location
and the size of the render tree elements
finally once done we issue a paint event
and our page is rendered on the screen
you know when we first started looking
at everything
it felt really confusing but this is
actually pretty straightforward this is
pretty awesome
glad to hear